[Music]
let's go to grace
in saint george utah what's up grace how
we doing
i'm good how are you i'm having a blast
what's up in your world
so basically i am a
resident assistant at my university
and
i've had a resident lately who has been
having
like really severe mental health issues
and um my boss has basically just asked
me to like keep checking in on her
and everything um but our university is
super understaffed um in the counseling
office i don't really have anywhere to
refer her to and so basically she's been
falling on me
to like check in on her but
i mean the first time i checked in on
her i had to call the emergency line
because
um she told me she was having
hallucinations and like intrusive
thoughts that were suicidal
and um basically i just don't really
know
uh
how to be a friend to her
um and also make sure that i'm
protecting myself yes and making sure
that i'm not getting hurt
you're you are very wise how old are you
grace
i'm 20. good for you you are wiser than
many many many folks twice your age so
good for you i'm glad that you are in
that role
um
lots of stuff here
let's
trying to figure out where to start here
um let's start with
just the state of the r.a position
so
i
how'd you find this show let me ask you
that
oh well i guess i still i've listened to
dave ramsey okay and i took his classes
in high school so um through the ramsay
show and you thought you would upgrade
and elevate and you defend our show here
i'm so glad that you're here um so for
those not listening the resident
assistant the ra position
um is
the live-in position so it's usually an
undergraduate student sometimes a
graduate student who lives in the
residence hall
with
college kids
and it can be a fun job but it is an
exhausting
frightening thankless job
and usually they way underpay you and
they give you room and they give you
like a free place to live which is great
it's awesome but that comes with 24 7
365
emergency care
mental health care
often you've probably held students who
are vomiting because they drank too much
and you're getting barfed on or bleeding
whatever it comes with so much stuff and
so it's 24 7 365.
um and then situations like this
so um grace tell me about the student
when you say having some significant
mental health challenges you mentioned
the student is
suicidal saying like i'm thinking about
hurting myself um
they've talked about they're
hallucinating tell me what else is going
on in that in the life of this student
yeah um so when she talked to me she
said that she like hadn't gotten out of
bed for three days
and she said like
her thoughts are like she's like they're
not like my own thoughts
um but she's still having them like
she'll have thoughts telling her to hurt
herself but she's like i don't want to
do that
um and then she's also having
hallucinations
um and her parents aren't real
supportive
and again the university doesn't really
offer what
they say they're going to offer sure um
so
so
here's here's where universities have
found themselves and having been in this
exact role
i'll tell you here's the challenges
psychologists have found themselves
they've really found themselves in a
no-win game here's why
um
when someone has a mental health
diagnosis it's an ada 504 issue okay so
you can't treat somebody differently
because of their disability
so you can't make a student who
um
is challenged with mobility who gets
around in a wheelchair
you can't say well you can't be a
biology major because that building
doesn't have a elevator so sorry you
gotta pick from our other majors you
can't do that you can't treat them
differently
you it's responsible you're responsible
for providing accessibility to the to
the biology lab to the classrooms
and so
when you get to mental health issues
like this
they become really messy really fast
because
i can't tell a student you have to leave
my college because then i'm treating
them differently
i can't tell a student you can't
have access to this part of the campus
because i'm violating their disability
at the same time
there's there's court cases where a
student took their life
they died by suicide
and the school was held liable
and so now schools have found themselves
in this weird um and for a season there
was a few years where they used the
the disciplinary the student conduct
code as a way to get rid of students to
say hey you are no longer safe to this
environment to this community you have
to leave which then they successfully
sued that you're violating my
my disability rights you can't kick me
out because i have a mental health issue
and so now schools are like what do we
do and then you throw in the massive um
financial issues that many many many
schools are having across the country
and then you get to where you are grace
where
you're a 20 year old undergraduate
student who is
trying to get your
degree
and you're an r.a and then somebody
unbelievably like i'm visibly um i'm
trying to talk a little bit too much
right now because i'm i'm angry on your
behalf that anyone would ever tell an
undergraduate student hey uh just check
on him
and you've got somebody who has said
i've got voices in my head telling me to
kill myself
and your supervisor would say well just
um
just um just keep an eye on him
right
man
so here's a few things that i would do
if i'm in your situation
number one i need you to know that
that's an unethical response that it's
an unethical situation you've been put
in the middle of and i hate that for you
um
it's never the responsibility of a
student employee or a paraprofessional
employee to deal with somebody who says
i'm gonna kill myself that's when the
adults in the room have to show up okay
um
so i'm sorry that you've been put in
that situation the first thing i would
do is
you look in the mirror i need you to
hear me say this directly
this is uh major psychiatric issues that
go well beyond my capabilities
okay so if somebody came into my office
and told me what that student has told
you which has happened i can't even
count how many times that exact
conversation has happened
i even with all the training and
experience i've got would take that
student and make sure they were in
contact with on or off campus resources
okay so that's not your job right now
but i need you to hear me say you can't
heal there's not a thing you can say to
this student that they're going to go oh
there's not a um
this has exceeded your ability right
your capacity and so i need you to make
sure that you are not feeling
responsible for this student's
well-being their mental health issues um
we are we are into psychiatry territory
now okay
that's hard for you because you're
somebody who helps you wouldn't even
have this job all right do you feel
yourself trying to take this all on
a little bit yeah okay um more so i've
just been worried about like
not taking it on like
really trying to like not
um not feel responsible okay all right
so the second thing i would do is um put
in writing what you've experienced and
make sure that
your
director of residence life the the
assistant dean over housing or however
whatever your thing that they have that
in front of them and
that's going to include your resident
hall director
okay and there's going to be some sort
of you're getting me like you jumped the
line or you should not have sent this to
this person you should have sent it to
me the resident director and i the hall
director and they i should have sent it
to
this is a point where somebody has told
you i'm hearing voices and they're
telling me to kill myself
so
i'm calling in all the cavalry calling
in everybody
you know what i mean and if somebody
fires you for that oh
your lawsuit will be incredible okay
so okay um i would put in writing
i need everyone to be on the same page
with this
this student has said the following
and i feel unequipped to be responsible
for the mental health care of the
student
and let them
be take over from there my guess is you
will probably get some sort of heat for
sit in that email okay and here's what i
want the reason i want you to send
emails i want you to put it in writing
that you as a 20 year old have been
asked to
well you just check on them and let us
know how things are going and that you
feel increasingly ill-equipped and
unprepared for dealing with a student
who has said i'm hearing voices and i'm
going to kill myself
okay
and so if heaven forbid something does
happen
you can say i put everybody on notice
that i was not equipped for this and
this was not part of my
job also the school many schools have
students who exceed their capacity for
care that's normal it's the school's job
and i've had to have all kinds of
conversations throughout my career
to get off-campus resources lined up for
their students if they're telling their
parents that
um we're taking care of your kids and so
it should be if the counseling center
doesn't have care great it should be
that there's partnerships with local
hospitals local mental health resources
local psychiatric units and things
that we can send this kid to sounds like
your college does not have that is that
right
they do
sort of
um but it's like the on-campus one is
supposed to be free and so then when
they refer people off campus and they
have to like make sure that they get it
covered and insurance and things and i
just don't know how supportive her
parents are and
okay all of that so so what i would tell
you is this
unfortunately
some people and you've dealt with this i
know you have have crummy parents
they have parents who don't show up or
they have extraordinary parents who
simply don't have the financial means
they don't know what to do next
and
it's really hard when you love somebody
and you care about them to be frustrated
about their parents but that's not
something that you can handle that's not
on you okay
um hopefully
hopefully
you have a dean of students or a vice
president for student affairs who's
reaching out to the parents saying we
have a major major situation here your
child is not okay they are threatening
to hurt themselves in our residence hall
they're hearing voices and we have to
get them the care they need and i can't
tell you how many times i've made that
phone call in my career
so it's normal it's part of the job it
should happen
and there does come a moment when the
students care needs do exceed the
capacity of the institution to help out
and that's when the 504 the the
disability services office and the dean
of students that's what everybody
partners together for what we do next
um
and their job is to partner with the
parents not yours
okay
and
it is okay to care and the best way you
can care for this student this young
woman is to make sure everybody knows
how serious this is
um is every are you confident that
everybody knows the status of this deal
i i would think so
um when i call the emergency line then
um they bring in like some sort of um
like assessment team and they assess her
for um risk and um and every time
they've just been like well she's clear
okay
so here's the thing this is gonna be
hard for you
just trust the team because that's their
professional job
and you might think oh no oh no the
student may be telling you one thing and
then another that's why writing down
having it writing is important but if a
team comes in trust the team
as hard as that is trust the team
one other thing you might do is um
contact somebody in the counseling
office that you have a relationship with
whether it's one of the staff therapist
or the director of the counseling center
and write them an email too and say this
student has continued to tell me
that they're suicidal that they're this
that they're this that they're that
can you please give me a few tips on
what i should do when they say this
and again you're letting another
professional in your world understand
exactly what's going on here
and final thing keep calling
if you call 9-1-1 and they show up and
they clear somebody and they leave and
it happens an hour later call 9-1-1
again and then call 9-1-1 again because
that's the only tool they've given you
is this is this number right to call
this assessment team
um
i will also tell you this this is hard
to hear i have worked with i came to
hundreds of ras in my career and
sometimes ras
because they live with the students
because they really care deeply
they feel like they've got more insight
than anybody else they feel like they
actually are the ones who know more
and so i would trust the professionals
in the world around you
that's hard because you're going to feel
like you aren't doing anything
they may not be doing anything for a
reason so
send the emails make sure the adults in
the room know exactly what's being said
exactly what's going on keep caring and
care by passing this information along
and then trust the professionals in your
world ugh that's such a hard job being
an r.a thank you for being brave and
courageous and for leaning into people's
lives and for everybody listening make
the call
make the call
most of us are not equipped to deal with
this kind of stuff make the call